hello and welcome my name is amanda
rodriguez-smith and i manage university
engagement for global robotics here at
amazon we recognize that the future of
tech starts now and that by investing in
stem education in schools and colleges
we're preparing the next generation of
tech leaders to thrive as professionals
into the future
it's for this reason that we are also
very excited to host today's
conversation with members of our amazon
science community and faculty from
hampton university hampton university is
one of north america's leading
institutions for engineering computer
science and aviation and now we are
working together to establish a robotics
degree program and along with that a
fully equipped robotics research lab
internships and career opportunities
which we believe hand-in-hand support
opportunities for students and faculty
to learn side by side with us here in
industry
programming is underway
and it's through intentional
collaborations like this that we're all
working to ensure that the technology
that we create is shared and shaped
broadly by diverse
interdisciplinary scholars and
innovators
and we are also deeply proud to uplift
the legacy of innovation at historically
black colleges and universities
including the visionary leadership who
have made this initiative
possible
we have many people to thank including
faculty members instructors
mentors and we also want to especially
recognize our pioneering champions dr
william harvey president of hampton
university
and amazon robotics chief technology
officer ty brady
so it's without further ado that i'm
excited to kick things off and i'd now
like to introduce my colleague jovanna
thiebert jovana is the director of
business strategy for amazon robotics
and she'll be leading our fireside chat
with an esteemed panel of faculty from
hampton university's schools of
engineering and computer science so stay
tuned to learn more about our
partnership and opportunities to get
involved and of course you can always
visit
amazon.science for the full scoop so
it's over to you joe
thank you amanda for the introduction
and for the overview of our partnership
with hanson university
i'd like to take time to introduce our
fireside chat participants
first i'd like to introduce dr elisa
harrison
then i'd like to introduce dr jane
muhammad and finally i'd like to
introduce dr demetrius gettis
dr harrison please let us know some of
your background and
where you are at the university
well hello my name is alyssa harrison
and i'll start off by saying i was
always interested in science technology
engineering and mathematics
stem
even as a young child
i always loved science i majored in
chemistry at
hbcu howard university and minored in
math
as a lifelong learner i got an
additional degree in computer science
after graduating because of my interest
in programming
as a spouse of a now retired military
officer
i then picked up certifications in
networking
project management and as an instructor
as part of my stem journey
after obtaining my master's in
administrative science from george
washington university i continued to
work in technology
and in industry and also in as a federal
contractor
after receiving my doctorate i then
continued on after we moved to virginia
and i purposefully sought out a role
with an hbcu
my journey led me to hampton university
where i can help students faculty staff
and the community at large through my
technical experiences in my role as the
vice president for information
technology
thank you dr harrison and it's a
pleasure to have you on our panel today
dr mohammed please share with us what
your journey was getting into tech and
towards becoming a hampton university
faculty member
i started out as a mathematics major as
an undergrad and decided that that
wasn't quite for me
and but i loved math and i looked over
to accounting did that for a little bit
and decided i didn't like it at all then
i found computer science took one
programming class and i was hooked
it was
interesting exciting it changed all the
time
i had some wonderful teachers
and as far as i was concerned that was
going to be my major and i've stuck with
it all this time
i moved on after my undergraduate degree
and i started
three computer institutes for women in
saudi arabia
and that was an exciting experience i
took my children my husband and all of
us was there and it was it was very
exciting to see those women just so
interested in technology that they were
not allowed to learn before that time
and so i was there for five years i came
back
finished my master's degree
and went to work for at t bell
laboratories and i was with a tnt for 10
years and loved every minute of that but
my always my passion was education
so i decided to go on and get a phd from
florida state
and
this is where i end up i've taught at
florida a m i've taught at florida state
and found my way to hampton and i've
been here for 16 years and i have not
regretted it one day i love what i do
and i always wanted to teach at an hbcu
wonderful thank you so much for sharing
a little bit more of your journey and
thank you for your energy
that you bring as a hamptons faculty
leader
and dr gettys let's round with you
can you share with us what your personal
journey was in coming into tech
and how you became a faculty member at
hampton university
well uh thanks again uh for uh having me
uh to participate in this uh fireside
chat um so when you say journey uh when
i look back um over
um
you know my my
path to becoming a professor here is
very interesting
especially you know being the first in
my family to go to college
um so as a young african-american
male you know growing up in south
carolina
in middle school it was all about being
a professional football player um
and so but at the same time i always
loved mathematics
and so as a sophomore in high school one
of my counselors said you know what are
you going to do if football doesn't work
out for you
and i said well you know i like
electricity i like math and so
i participated in an electricity
program
at my high school really enjoyed it
um again being the first of my family to
go to college i was or even think about
college i was thinking about maybe going
and becoming an electrician
and my electricity teacher said
demetrius you're in pre-calculus now and
uh you like electricity why aren't you
thinking about engineering
and so um so what is an engineer
so going through that process
looking up schools and i found my way
here by my home by the sea here at
hampton university
uh in 1994
and i met professors like dr muhammad
um and and others
and so
you know so i you know i got exposed to
research at a at an early stage in my
academic career at hampton so i enrolled
as an electrical engineering major
and uh worked at nasa
and um someone asked me about graduate
school i was like well what is what is
graduate school what do you do at
graduate school and so that's that hbcu
experience that you know here you have
first in the family to go to college not
really knowing what a phd is
and then meeting professors like like dr
muhammad and in my case dr alfonso smith
uh giving me that first opportunity to
do research with them at nasa
and so
from hampton i ended up going to georgia
tech for graduate school so
um you know and and that experience
again
um you know when you know if you think
about
um
many of us
you know who are faculty
um
going to graduate school for the first
time
your family not really understanding you
know that situation it's a it's a very
interesting path
but it made me
you know when it was time for me to
graduate from graduate school
think think about that journey
and that's sort of what led me back back
to an hbcu so i actually after
graduating um helped start a engineering
program at one of our
at norfolk state university
and um but i always wanted to give back
to my alma mater and i found myself back
here at hampton for the last five years
leading the department of electrical and
computer engineering
wonderful
well i'm glad your journey found its way
back to hampton
and just to pull on that thread a little
bit more you talked about
doing research and working in different
areas
you know hampton university is known as
a leader in science education can you
share a little bit more about its unique
history and the legacy of that
achievement
um
so hampton as you said before and most
hbcus um have a unique history so you
know being founded in in 1868
uh we were founded as a normal and
agricultural institute
and so that normal part meant that we
were actually training the next leaders
for our community uh to go back and be
teachers
and so you know 80 percent of the people
who graduated from hampton went back to
these communities these you know
one-room shacks and they actually were
teaching newly freed people
um and so it's just funny that i found
my way back into that profession as well
too
um but we also were we were an institute
um and we were founded to learn by doing
and um also one of our you know models
is you know training the hand the head
and the heart
and so when you think about that
the training of the hand the head and
the heart to me that is actually
engineering
right so you got to be you got to be a
critical thinker but you also got to get
you know your hands on something and
actually create something and at the
root of the of the institute that's what
we were actually um you know preparing
graduates for not just for teaching but
also um actually doing real world
innovation or or you know using using
those skills for for things like that so
you know one of our uh famous alums you
know burger t washington who ended up
taking that principle and
and and and starting tuskegee uh
institute as well too
uh so it's been at the heart so if you
look at our history
in in the the 1900 early 1900s it was
more trades work
as we got closer to the mid 1950s we
started the department of technology
and then by the 60s we actually had you
know an engineering program
um and then if you continue on in the
80s we actually had computer science
aviation we got into
more and more um
the modern day technology as as you have
today and so now we're we're we're ready
for for machine learning and ai and all
those other things as well too
and we're excited that you're ready it's
it is amazing that uh
hampton had the foresight
to make sure you're not only teaching
about um science technology but also
leadership to your students and you
talked about
hand head and heart
uh i'm like yes engineering and and
leadership so i i'm excited that that is
still a key principle
um or at least a foundation for the
university and and fooling on that dr
mohamed
i want to talk about
you know hbcus are not only competing
but they're leading and thriving
how are hbcus paving the way
specifically around
sciences like robotics machine learning
and artificial intelligence
let me start by saying that
hbcus across the landscape
are very collaborative bunch especially
in stem
computer science and i know engineering
as well
and so
they are all
men
on the cuspis of being very excited
about being engaged into artificial
intelligence about data science and
robotics as well hampton university of
computer science department was
previously engaged in a collaborative
robotic initiative
when i first got here 16 years ago and
we had 17 hbcus involved and some pwis
and they did a tremendous a lot of work
engaging our students with the interest
in robotics now moving forward
right now the real interest across that
landscape is artificial intelligence
and machine learning
all of our hvcus do not have that
particular expertise but they're
collaborative with each other and trying
to develop that
and we're excited to be involved in
artificial intelligence we have some
faculty who are engaged in that we in
fact are a part of a consortium and a
grant that engages seven hbcus
and we are doing engaging um artificial
intelligence cyber security and bringing
in our students
um to engage in research in those
particular areas we are not where we
want to be
but we are we're definitely have our
feet in the pool and we are engaged with
it we're excited we're trying to build
more capacity in that and i'd like to be
able to add another piece to that our
president dr harvey has initiated our
department and along with dr harrison
and have said that he wants hampton
university to have a major in artificial
intelligence and machine learning and we
are
going full steam ahead to make that
happen once dr harvey says he wants
something believe me we make sure that
we go forward and we make sure to make
it happen and so
not just hampton you'll find that kind
of interest interest across the hbcu
landscape they are right there trying to
get in that particular arena and make a
difference locally as well as globally
wonderful
i you know
this is starting to paint the picture
for it sounds like a vision
and i want to hear more about what's
hampton's vision for the future of
technology and science research
and feel free to share any programs that
you currently offer
at your university and also expand
through what collaborations with
industry or initiatives
like our partnership and dr harrison
i'll start with you
i'm glad you asked that question it's a
wonderful question and i'd like to
continue with what dr muhammad just
mentioned with the vision because
hampton university's technology vision
aligns with our overall strategic vision
and what uh some of the platforms and
things that dr harvey has put in place
for the future to build on what we had
were some recent network and
infrastructure upgrades to support our
students our faculty our staff
our research programs
and it is through collaborative excuse
me collaboration with industry partners
such as amazon robotics
for example we recently received grants
through the student freedom initiative
to enhance our cyber security
infrastructure and that positions the
university as a competitor for federal
grants and other things like the that
specify for example the national
institute of standard and technology
missed compliance
through the
national telecommunications information
administration ntia grant we hope to
expand hampton university's broadband
access by improving the university's
internet access
connectivity through installations and
upgrades of our broadband
uh facilities offering services
equipment digital skill instruction
training
for our students and furthering our
broadband access in adoption to digital
skills
and remote learning opportunities
through employment entrepreneurship
through the minority businesses within
our surrounding communities so there's a
lot of things that we want to do and
this investment that
amazon robotics proposed at the start of
this
engagement furthers hampton's
cloud-based robotic
research infrastructure improvements and
stem-based activities to increase our
overall talent pool our pipeline while
supporting hampton university's own
digital transformation
with a stronger infrastructure we will
truly support the schools of science and
the schools of engineering and
technology as well as the entire campus
because it's not just limited to stem
you look we have to look at business
school school of liberal arts and
sciences
it will help us further the technology
of our university so there's a lot of
things that come from this collaboration
and i was pleased to engage with amazon
robotics at the start with so many
individuals
uh we haven't mentioned one ty brady he
his vision helped our vision go further
definitely and
ty couldn't be with us today but he
definitely is excited to see the vision
and partnership flourish and you know dr
gettys and dr muhammad i'll turn it over
to both of you to add if you um see
other additions and and pieces to that
future vision
well i i think just just to add to
to what dr harrison uh said is
um you know robotics and i heard dr
muhammad mentioned earlier cyber
security all those are like um
multi-disciplinary
type programs so artificial intelligence
machine learning robotics
it's sort of bringing these different
areas together
so you know within my department you
know computer engineering
is is very hot because the students
actually get to see that they sort of
sit somewhat in the middle where they
they have to have the software skills
they have to have those hardware skills
and
you know all those things are going to
work together to help us innovate in the
machine learning artificial intelligence
cyber security space so i can see sort
of in the future in terms of you know
the momentum with having strong computer
science program engineering programs and
having students prepared
for this multi-disciplinary space
and you know hampton is providing that
platform for our students
and dr muhammad i'll turn it over to you
if you have anything else to add for
that vision
thank you for that introduction and yes
i would like to add something to that
uh the department of computer science
has three undergraduate programs which
is computer science computer information
systems and cyber security we are a
center of excellence through nsa and
homeland security and cyber security
in addition to that we have a lot of
corporate partners that we have helped
us get there including amazon with the
robotics program that our students are
so excited about we've had several of
our students go out in this new program
and intern in the summer and we look
forward to some of them doing the same
this summer
in addition to that
we are involved in a google in residence
program that i would like to talk to
amazon about at some point and so that
program is where we have a google
engineer come on campus every fall and
we've been doing that for about seven
years now their interest is the early
student they want to grab the freshman
so they provide a course for the
freshman incoming freshmen
and they teach them and they do more
than just teach them the programming
skills what they do is teach them how to
do a technical interview
what does that mean what how to prepare
themselves for that and then at the same
time they get better internships not
just with google but across industry and
that helps not just the freshmen but
they're engaged with the upperclassmen
as well
in addition to that
we have a pre-college program that we're
very very excited about we've been doing
that for about six years now we bring in
incoming freshmen
and
who have not had a lot of computer
science some of them haven't had any but
they've chosen computer science as a
desirable major for themselves
and if we bring them into the program
without anything what we have found when
i first came to hampton is that they
struggled and then at that point they
some of them changed their major
but by bringing them into the
pre-college program getting them ready
firing them up making sure they come
into that first programming course
knowing how to program that they did
over the summer
we have found that our retention rate
has tremendously increased and so that
would that has proved to be very
exciting and we've had
many different types of corporations
that have helped us because we don't
want the students to pay what we don't
want the parents to do is to have to
make a decision do i pay for their
tuition or do i send them here for that
program
so we have corporate pro
we have corporate sponsors that let them
come for free and so that has been an
exciting program that we've had for the
last six years so those are just some of
the things that we've been doing with
our students and meeting the students
where they are
some of them are ready some of them are
not but what we have found that they can
learn to do this and they can get
excited about it and they can go out
into industry
and graduate school and make a
tremendous contribution
and if i can chime back in as well too
so one of the things that the
partnership amazon partnership
so you guys have joined um something
that we've done with some of our
industry partners in terms of
participating in our capstone so you
know this has been you know tremendous
for our students so one of the reasons
why we want our students to actually
engage with uh industry is that they get
to see sort of you know why they have
been preparing why did they struggle
through that curriculum in computer
science or computer engineering or
electrical engineering yeah they get to
see you guys so you know i you know
amazon
mentors have been great you know they've
given our students something to aspire
to
but it also you know makes them
um
they work a little harder when they
actually are um you know doing a project
that actually have you know people in
the real world not just dr gettys uh
looking over and saying hey
so that's been tremendous
i also would like to give a shout out
to you guys for
um investing in uh faculty at the
institute
so you guys have made a commitment to
help us um bring in an endowed uh
professor
and so that's gonna that's gonna
definitely help as well too you know in
terms of this journey so you know seeing
another engineer um you know inspire the
next generation so thank you guys for
for making that commitment to the
university as well
you know we are more than elated to to
have this partnership and we find that
when we are partnering and the
partnership is a two-way
we are investing in the faculty and the
students
at the same time it's helping us as
being the world's best employer to make
sure our employees coming in they're
ready to go
because we have a bar that we continue
to raise um that we're striving to the
the next level of technology and science
so thank you all for helping us bridge
that gap for the the partnership
and yes dr muhammad we are always up for
uh the next challenge and making sure
our mentorship um deepens uh with with
the students along with yourselves
so we've got
one more question here
and i'll open it to each of you
you know for many of the students the
conversations like that we're having
right now uh introducing them into
opportunities and careers in stem
what's your advice to those
uh tuning in that are seeking guidance
or mentorship or advancement where do
they start and what are some of the
resources they can get access to
we have a lot of programs hampton
university i believe is first in class
about the programs that they have
and how they outreach to the communities
and not just in the local communities
the hampton roads communities and
bringing in middle school students
bringing in high school students
giving them that exposure and that's
across computer science that compose
across engineering it's even in the in
the science and technology physics all
of these areas and to mine i'd like to
say that i go back to saying hampton is
first in class for instance we have
a
girls academy
that we bring in young ladies and we
expose them to computer science so
that's just one we have an apple coding
for all
that we haven't been able to do due to
covet face to face but we've been doing
it virtually and so
anyone can come in virtually and they
can learn how to utilize technology and
many of them have nev don't even have
that in high school they've never done
it before or middle school
the engineering department
they have had a long-standing program
with some of their core their industry
partners with a verizon program with
middle school boys i was a part of that
with them for engineering and computer
science
there is just so many programs across
hampton's campus
now in addition to that
we have so many um opportunities with
high school days
we have um all of these kind of product
programs that they can just come in
visit hampton it's been a little
restricted now because of covid but
they've been virtual
and so these students have been able to
come in virtually and see what we're
doing meet all of the departments in
stem
not just them on the soft lines as well
and their business departments all of us
and meet us talk to our students engage
with our students we're mentoring a lot
of our students uh these students in the
community virtually
so they get to see
students as freshmen
as sophomores as juniors as seniors and
see that they can do it now these are
students of color so they're seeing our
students engaged in research they see
them engaged in the mentoring part in
the programming part in the engineering
part
all of that is happening whether we're
physically on campus or whether we're
doing this virtually so there's been no
time in my 16 years that i have not seen
hampton university reaching out to the
community talking to the students
bringing them in letting them see what
we do
but in addition to that we're inviting
them if they see this video to please
just pick up the phone and call us
talk to us we're willing to talk to them
bring our students in on zoom or any
other platform and engage with them and
let them know what we're doing and
invite them to join our departments
wonderful thank you dr mohamed and we'll
make sure to put um your contact
information for the the department as
well dr gettys you know while we're
rolling you know let's let's go to you
next
uh that was that was really really good
uh very comprehensive um you know again
i i think about myself and the exposure
one of the things uh that so
i actually
am the pi for nsf grant and we actually
have you know outreach programs and so
we have our undergraduate students go
out to you know local high schools or
local middle schools
and you know either do experiments or
present to them have panel sessions to
talk about that transition from high
school to college so there are different
opportunities for students to sort of
engage
and most hbcus especially the ones that
have engineering programs they may
actually partner
with a local high school and start a
national society of black engineers
junior chapter so a nesby junior chapter
and so you might want to look at some of
the nesbi junior chapters that are in
your area
and you may be able to use that to
connect to
not not just hbcus it could be um
other universities as as well too
um but i think um
like you said you want to be proactive
you want to reach out to the
universities and you definitely can go
to our website
or you know be able to
look up my my get my contact information
and contact me uh if you're in the local
area
but if nationally we have upward bound
programs that partner with us
um where we actually have what we call
exploratory saturday where they and you
know high school middle school students
come to campus
and the physics chemistry engineering
departments actually uh demo you know
put on different demonstrations for them
um and so
i'm sure that those those things exist
in in your area as well too but you got
to reach out to the local universities
and see what they have going on because
the pipe we need more students coming
into this pipeline that's that's right
one of the one of the one of the things
that um again with the national science
foundation is how can we increase the
number of students actually entering the
pipeline you know surviving the pipeline
is as is an issue but getting the
numbers
um um to actually have an interest in
stem
is a national it's a national need
definitely and that's a great segue and
dr harrison i'm going to come over to
you oh yeah perfect i'm going to come
over to you too
i wanted to piggyback on dr getting
because that brings us full circle to
why we started with amazon and the first
thing that we discussed in that proposal
of what how we should engage it started
with internships but then we as dr
harvey would say we dreamed a larger
dream because we don't dream small
dreams here and it was establish a
pipeline so all of these different
programs that we have helped to
establish a program we like to embed
some of this into there
creating that capstone
project that is one thing because that's
important
and that was part of that
background and purpose for this
identifying faculty support
and then we haven't talked about the
amazon and hampton university
uh robotics research lab
that is a visual on our second floor
that brings students in and they're
actually hands-on and engaged that's
something that came out of that as well
and those credits that were provided as
part of this grant that we have with
amazon robotics let them back up their
information so it's not just let's start
it you're helping us with the
infrastructure
the uh two other areas that we didn't
speak a lot about were creating a
portfolio stem project and that's
both
schools are working on that so in the
summer we're starting not just with high
school but we're going to reach back to
middle school and bring them into it and
lastly but not least would be the drone
project and dr gettys you could have
talked a little bit about that because
that partnership is coming out of school
of engineering i'll throw it back to you
to just say what they're doing because
you mr murray is involved with that yes
coordinate over the summer so yes that's
and that's definitely again that
you know we actually have aviation
within the school of engineering and
technology and so you know we actually
train pilots but you know um uh
autonomous uh vehicles such as uh uavs
are hot right now we need pilots for
those so we actually are um you know
working with you guys to host the
uh drone camps
um and so that again is that like you
said that pipeline so that's
not only uh we're using our students to
actually train the next generation so we
got undergraduate students
working with faculty members and helping
you know k-12 or inspire k-12
with these with these drone competitions
and drone camps
so
uh yes definitely
a plus that's another plus that i that i
left out in terms of
amazon's expertise linked with uh
hampton's expertise in terms of aviation
as well
that was wonderful so
i i know we're out of time
but i want to just say thank you again
on behalf of our robotics team on behalf
of amazon for
just continuing to work with us on this
partnership and helping us see what
curiosity spaces there are with the
students the faculty and the community
and where we can continue to come
alongside you
of training our next leaders for
what does it look like for that hand
head heart
foundation and engineering and
leadership that's right
and so to close out and i just want to
put this out there a little bit so dr
harrison where can the students go
to make sure they learn more
opportunities there at hampton
we have our a website that's the hampton
university and amazon robotics which
will have
a timeline so it shows everything that
we've done since we started a calendar
who's on the robotics team and um
we need to add the students dr gettys
and dr mohamed because they're part of
this team
we need at the amazon robotics point of
contact individuals because they're part
of this team and there'll be a gallery
so all that will be provided on a link
that will send to you soon
wonderful okay
thank you so much yes it's so exciting
and thank you all for joining us and and
listening into
uh our wonderful partnership with
hampton university and with that
take care
all right thank you
thank you so much
it's been an experience that we hope to
continue